produtos inúteis da internet OK nós
temos aqui um casal ela vai cortar o
próprio cabelo para fugir do namorado
entendi faz tudo o sentido olha meteu
uma jarra ali What the fuck Ok já subiu
num banco já pegou na chave escondida Ok
o que é que ela deve ter ali escondido
abriu a porta toma encomendas da China
uh muitos produtos já estou a ver olha
olha já pegou na caixa ok O que é isto
um inspirador Rô não é quecedor que dor
de quê aquest dor de sapato Bem podre é
um ótimo produto ok uma estante para
chinelos inútil completamente inútil Ui
que é isto um dispensador de arroz Oh
que maravilha bem podre Olha que é isto
faz arroz aquela máquina olha um ralador
de queijo não é cenoura não é alho
francês não é kii ai meu Deus é muita
coisa OK um arrumador de facas bem podre
inútil meu mete ISO tenta gaveta aposto
custo aia meu Deus que inútil